taylor qui était edmond rostand
l'écrivain derrière la célèbre pièce
cyrano de bergerac
joël bats est un peu c'est un honneur
asthénique qui prennent des pilules qui
boit la verveine
j'ai une vie plate mais sous pression en
décembre 1897
edmond rostand va écrire en trois
semaines seulement un grand texte qui a
du coeur de l'esprit et du panache lui
mon restant est passé de d'un illustre
inconnu à pau est national en une
journée dans sa vie au fait avec ça
c'est fascinant découvrir si on découvre
bien d'autres choses sereinement restant
dans la pièce
edmond de l'auteur français alexis
michalik présenté à juste pour rire
on apprend aussi que tous ces partis
aussi digne d une muse qu'il a
complètement fait rêver et puis qui le
complètement inspiré la trame narrative
d'edmond est en effet en grande partie
vrai mais alexis michalik ses gardes et
la liberté d'inventer des personnages
comme se tenant ces deux barres noires
pris par sa fougue inspira l'auteur de
cyrano de bergerac la scène du nez qui
devient péninsule de savères dix maires
de façon très poétique de dire un [ __ ]
vous auriez pu dire de façon
géographique artistique peintre qu'un
pic comme la tirade d'unités c'est fort
et puis pour moi il coûte
d'extraordinaire dans une mise en scène
très rythmique edmond est aussi une
leçon de théâtre
on comprend bien qu avant la levée du
rideau tout peut arriver
je t'aime petit miracle c'est l'odeur a
comme la moitié des spectacles qu'on
fait on vous fait toujours croire
les journalistes en est que tout va bien
mais une fois sur deux on est dans la
merde on sait pas si on va y arriver on
a pas finis les éclairages le costume
nous a lâché hier soir rien acteurs qui
s'est foulé une cheville
il ne reste plus qu'à dire le mot de
cambronne et a souhaité qu'à la fin de
l'envoi
elles montrent touche ici louis philippe
ouimet radio canada montréal